hi I'm Marla Thomas Fletcher and I am a
filmmaker I'm a writer director producer
I've written over 25 films short films
and basically I consider myself a
screenwriter first and foremost but i
have written of two feature films one
feature film called the lonesome trail
which is in post-production and i'm
trying to get finishing funds for and
then also a pilot film which is called
where's daddy which is also in
post-production however we're talking
about screenwriting and i love to write
that's what I love to do I love to write
about life about things all around that
are going on current events but I love
to write about family relationships and
right now I'm writing a film called a
screen place called The Legend of carter
dotson and that screenplay is an
extension of a film that I did which is
a Western film which I told you it's
called the lonesome trail the reason why
I'm doing this is because I actually
love westerns and I like sharing family
films so I'm trying to do kind of a
trilogy of these westerns that's kind of
why I'm doing it my goal as a
screenwriter is to break into the
industry and get to you know get that
kind of programming out there more also
I've been doing this for about 10 years
I really enjoy doing it and I'm looking
forward to being able to do more writing
and also get my work into the mainstream
thank you so much